today's topic steven crowder I saw a
video he did and I wanted to react to it
so this is a response to look at this
right here you can clearly see this was
just to be just to be clear before I've
been here before it was not an indoor
outdoor patio
it was blacklivesmatter riots people are
saying well you know what this is what
we have to do because peaceful protests
aren't allowed when when Colin
Kaepernick peacefully protest you tell
him to shut up no no no one has a
problem with Colin Kaepernick going to a
park and taking a knee people need to be
clear the problem there wasn't with a
peaceful protest the problem there was
with a man who was paid to play football
hijacking a multi-million dollar job to
make a political statement and people
have the right to vote with their dollar
and not support Colin Kaepernick your
whole persona out of here okay my
problem with that you say he was making
a political statement
what is the national anthem at every
sports game is it not a political
statement is it not a form of patriotism
so let me get this straight
you're fine with forms of political
statements that you like but the ones
that you don't are unacceptable and you
don't see something wrong with someone
saying hey I feel police brutality is
unacceptable I'm gonna do this in a
peaceful manner on a public and people
went nuts
alright people even veterans were fine
with what he was doing but everyone else
went crazy because they didn't want to
see that on their television and now you
ask yourself why are these riots
happening because people didn't want to
look at the reality of what's happening
in the USA so when you said that you're
like why are you doing this on the
television do it in a park where no one
can see well the whole part of awareness
is to put in places where you can't see
the same way the whole point of putting
the national anthem everywhere is to
remind you of that sense of patriotism
so if we could accept the national
anthem what is the problem with
accepting a need during the national
anthem which she's not hijacking because
he's not stopping the game no he's just
doing why everybody's standing that's
not that is not what I call hijacking
the cameras don't even have to be on him
so hijacking your brother your choice of
word is very poor
from jäger we will see it through
alright that pisses me off I guess we
can go with that
you know I see people talking about
Christians as well you know listen we
just need to be peaceful when you see
these police officers in Flint who Neal
did you see by the way did you see those
white guys who kneeled and ask for
forgiveness that's not but by the way
keep in mind how this that is right
asking white people all white people to
kneel and ask for forgiveness could you
imagine if white people asked all black
people to kneel and ask for forgiveness
for the cops were shot last night most
of us are not asking that nobody cares
if you kneel most of us don't do it
your forgiveness all right oh my god I'm
so nobody cares if you have privilege
nobody cares about none of that that's
not what people are asking for for the
most part so for you to strawman this
movement as if it's a real problem
stop it's not the reality of what's
going on right now it's not the white
people it's the organization of policing
even if I see a black cop I'm not good
with it I'm gonna be a bit because I see
a cop I see God because again some of
them were shot by white people I
understand it but not all white people
certainly not in 2020 are guilty of the
sin of slavery as far as what am I going
to kneel and a sign of peace to
de-escalate no I'm not going to kneel
and ask for forgiveness for something
that I've never done but I would like to
sit down and talk with people I would
like to sit down and hear what the
grievances are and what the goal is with
this the First Amendment allows you the
right to protest but that also it
requires that requires it should
necessitate petitioning right the right
to protest in particular what are they
petitioning justice okay
Derik Chauvin was charged with
third-degree murder they're
investigating the other police officer
and by the way from the top down from
Donald Trump
so not justice what do you need him to
be hung from the gallows
this does look like willful ignorance
that's not what they're asking for if
you think that people are still
protesting because of George Floyd then
you aren't listening and this is what I
said in the other video everyone wants
to flap their gums but no one's taking
the time to really understand the other
side and as a result all we have is just
noise being thrown out I mean sure your
fans are going to be happy because they
already share your views so you're
preaching to the choir it's an echo
chamber very easy to do
same way sjw's do with themselves all my
people are anxious Baba and they say
amongst themselves so they feel great
but it's not meaningful in any kind of
dialogue and this is the kind of stuff I
dislike you're asking what do they want
what is that they're asked for they're
asking for police reform they're asking
for better training what they see is
that systemically there are a lot of
problems with how police officers engage
in a lot of stuff and we're not the only
one saying that police officers
themselves or a lot of them are agreeing
with a lot of this sentiment but they
cannot fade out loud because they're
gonna lose their job there mmm he's not
a cop yeah he said he wanted to sit down
and talk not with this attitude you
claim you want to sit down and solve and
comprehend you don't you do not you have
your own ideas and your close minded to
that and you try to disprove the other
person and actually when that person is
proven wrong you get pissed off you
don't add episode you know what I'm
talking about yeah you look like a fool
on that one the point is you do not want
to sit down and listen caught up whether
it be our political views or ego wanting
to maybe relinquish some ground that
we're not willing to concede that the
other party may have a point and people
like well officers don't just shoot
black people okay great we're not asking
for police brutality the images against
black people we want it to end period
there's no black person it's like we
want police brutality the end against
just blacks keep killing the whites and
nobody's saying that so if you really
think that police brutality is a problem
then you should have no problem with
this move because it benefits you
inherently I don't understand these
counter arguments there's not a
complicated aspect to this again I'll
say for the 10,000th time I'm not
endorsing rioting I'm not endorsing
burning of buildings even though in the
other video we said we understand it we
never said we endorsed
or courtesan but I get frustrated
sometimes because like people with these
platforms just sit here in their
tone-deaf and they act clueless and I'm
like did you do a Google search so all
four of the officers have now been
charged and people are asking why do we
still need to protest and I think to
myself do not realize that the reason
why the officers were charged is because
people are protesting does that not
strike you as somehow very insidious
that people have to watch traumatic
videos online every time a shooting
happens then that video has to propagate
itself and go viral before officers DEA
is law enforcement everybody gets
involved in all of a sudden charge to
drop this is not strike two is on do you
think I want to watch [ __ ] videos of
men being gunned down by police officers
and just see what if I don't watch it
and it doesn't propagate itself that
nothing happens why is it that the only
time action happens is when I have to
click on videos and get outraged why
does that make any sense how does that
seem to you a system that works that's
why I keep telling people this is not
about the four men being arrested
anymore this is about a judicial
judicial system a policing system that
just seems so dysfunctional it only
takes one cop to write up a report and a
citizen gets arrested but it takes
millions of us to scream at the top of
our lungs to me like this is unjust
before things move same thing with your
Marberry video they had that for a while
they had it for a long time they didn't
care they didn't move on it all of a
sudden gets leaked to the public and now
charges are dropped and people are being
charged with murder I'm like how does
that make sense guys we don't know how
you two is gonna react to these videos
if you'd be monetizing monetizing things
it's been super confusing for me
so if you want to ensure that this video
does well please hit the like button it
helps us out a like comment help with
all that algorithm stuff and yeah we
also have a peach run you can check out
so if you want to see more of us we have
a podcast there do we want to go back to
the to the pre slavery or during slavery
type executions what well I understand
what justice is being demanded I see all
of these requests on Twitter we have one
simple request that officers stop
killing black people but apparently
that's too complicated what
what does what does that even mean that
black officers stopped killing the
officer stop killing black what about
white officers and black officer sorry
what about black officers who killed
white people let me tell you this preach
said it earlier but there's none of us
that like black officers more than white
officers I don't know what this idea
came from it's police period using
colors we've seen boys in the hood we've
seen all of those movies were not
winning a cop is a cop
period same thing with the Asian cop
that was standing by and you watch what
happened people chastise them as well
it's not about white cops specifically
though white cops are the predominant
presence in the police force doesn't
mean that it's just about that it's
about cops
period no one said please end white
police brutality against nobody saying
that it said leave brutality you see
that one yesterday the black cop black
cop who there was this angry black lady
who was punching a white police officer
in the face the white police officer did
nothing he can go find this at TMZ and
she'd punched him again and then a black
officer knocked her unconscious or as I
call it a happy ending at that point you
know why that you know why that officer
did that because he knew that if that
white officer responded to a woman who
was pummeling him he would be the next
direction of actually really good at
taking just one example how many just
prove your point just to disprove your
point you think that one example that
satisfies your need and that goes with
what you're saying you know damn well
that's not what the we're talking about
and yes there's gonna be instances of
people in the citizens going over and
that is not what we're talking about and
you know we hold there's plenty of
footage of black officers punching and
pushing black people all right it's all
over the internet you can find it right
now even during these rights and they're
not turning into the next Derek chill
thing so where that came from I have no
idea but I do think that this video was
poorly thought-out my honest opinion and
if I'm being also very honest I actually
have a friend who works for Crowder and
he speaks highly of them from an ethical
standpoint pays his employees on time
very generous good with where all that
good stuff and so it disappoints me when
I see what you put out publicly I'm like
this is dude it's not well done but what
I see a lot of people doing is that they
mocked social justice warriors for not
being nuanced for being ridiculous and
do all those stuff and then they
themselves refuse to see the nuance in
other people's positions
right like I can sympathize with
somebody who who identifies the
conservative I hold some conservative
views you know when it comes to Second
Amendment when it comes to the idea of
being able to own guts when it comes to
strict borders I get it but it bothers
me that people on the other side were
like nah nah these riots all riots yeah
black life matter it's inherently a
terrorist organization what are you
talking about do not recognize that you
engage in the exact same rhetoric that
you condemn on the other side do you not
see that listen I don't even know why
you so mad because he's doing this on
purpose this guy is a smart man he knows
what he's doing he knows exactly what
he's doing
I didn't say otherwise but it passes
himself as virtuous absolutely so that's
why and I understand that he knows what
he's doing and why he's doing it bad
pretty sure that if we talk to him 101
we're gonna be able to rationalize and
be like gonna understand but this no he
really believes what he sang really yeah
I don't think this is an act he really
believes and it's okay that he but at
least he's saying what he believes and I
hope it's what he believes because if
he's doing this first that's even worse
I know some people were doing hey I know
some people were having some dumb
mistakes I've ever heard but why are you
guys hurt by the death of tonight guys
officer Tatum dude he had a video that
he put our he's like I kid there people
are upset with this situation that they
saw with the he with the uh the black
man that was under the knee of their
police officer and even he passed away
but let me say this man let me let me
just say this I need people to stop
being so emotional if you didn't know
that man you don't you ain't you you
were you weren't concerned and I'm just
I'm just giving my opinion take it or
leave it
if you weren't concerned about that man
when he was alive I don't think it's
important for people to go up and beyond
and try to act like that's a boy or
something I'm just I'm just keeping it
you didn't know that man his whole life
you don't know who that man is
you don't know if there's a good man or
bad man like what you think when people
cry when they watch a movie it's because
they know the person know sometimes it
identifies with things that happen likes
just some dumb takes
but some of its disingenuous with this
one I'm like it's just disappointing
because you're engaging in what you
claim is bad but he treats the whole
thing as a joke it's a joke yeah the way
he does it the tone of it you know
everything is like a joke he's being
very sarcastic by everything he says so
in Louisville these men linked arms to
protect a police officer who got
separated from his squad outnumbered and
surrounded you can see the concern on
his face but he shield it until he can
get to safety
this guy was breaking chunks out of a
sidewalk in the nation's capital when
protesters turned on him and handed him
over to the cop
[Music]
you guys want to see we've covered this
topic in regards to the rights and all
this stuff
ad nauseam so if you can go check our
past videos be sure to do that and
that's about it
[Music]